To begin,
the Hombu Shihan,
Tada Hiroshi Sensei,
will give a speech.
Thank you very much.
First of all, Happy New Year everyone.
As it is the beginning of the year,
I’m sure all of you are motivated to practicing this coming year.
Regarding that, I would like to tell you a few things.
I have something here.
The is the first issue of the Aikikai Newspaper, that was published on April 1st, 1950.
I actually joined a month before this was issued, when I was a 20 years old student.
Everyone was talking about this paper that had everything you needed to know about Aikido.
It used to be called Ueshiba dojo back then.
It's still the Ueshiba Dojo now actually...
It taught Ueshiba Sensei’s style.
Before the war, the dojo was closed to the public,
and people couldn’t join without an introduction.
There is a story of someone from the Italian embassy
who insisted on joining the dojo and sat in front of the door for a week.
So Ueshiba Sensei not only taught the techniques but also the “Way”,
and why we were doing this.
Back then, every second Sunday,
we conducted something called Aiki no Kai.
We had a lot of important people back then
like politicians come to the convention.
And after that, Morihei Sensei would perform a demonstration and a lecture,
and the transcript was featured in the the following month’s issue of our newsletter,
even though it was just a few pieces of paper folded together.
And from there, it became Aikido’s Journal.
Almost 9 years later in April, 1959, the first issue of Aiki Journal was published.
Sorry for the state it's in, but what I am holding here is the first issue of this Aiki Journal.
You can read O sensei’s lessons in there.
Nowadays, we have DVD versions of all issues of Aiki Journal downstairs in the office,
which I hope you will read and learn a lot from.
Later, something like this was published for 9 years,
those stories became a single book called Aiki Shinzui
And this, it’s hard if you try to think as you read.
You have to feel as you read.
Just like you learned to do things by doing as a child, you won’t know until you do it.
What is the “Way” [michi]? There are two Ways in one michi,
one is Shingaku, and another is Shinpo.
Shingaku is based on Koshi and Moshi’s studies in Edo era,
and bushido came from there.
Shinpo no michi is based on the universe.
Humans are living.
Planet is living.
And the universe is living too.
And how do we live and what can we do to increase the energy of the universe?
How do we develop our skills?
That is michi.
And there is only one thing you need to remember.
Don’t do things like you are obsessed.
And in modern days, we have the Olympic Games in a few years,
those people do such things as mental training and mental management,
and image training within those.
And all those things have traditionally been the components of Shinpo no michi.
That’s the michi that we have had in the East since 3000 years ago.
So the Aikido that we are doing is the michi that best reflects the tradition.
The latest thing people in the US and Europe are doing,
similar to michi,
we have been practicing for as long as we can trace back,
and I hope you understand that and work hard, not only on the skills.
Then you will get to learn how to increase your energy,
overcome sickness and allergies.
Let's do this this year!